wide receivers yeah right I mean you
know the knock on wide receivers they're
all Primadonna you know that whole thing
right but there's a pretty Elite group
that you're a part of who
everyone's a little bit different yeah
but who do you think is generally the
greatest receivers that have played
obviously Bryce is at the top right I
mean whoever played and think they is
yeah but it's all what you believe
whoever played what and I say whoever
played and think they were you know what
I'm saying you're only as great as to
what you believe yeah but I'm saying but
obviously it's a code of conduct of
ethics of what people per se is great
you know your numbers your stats your
touchdowns so there's a lot of level of
greatness of how you can prepare players
Some People based on you know how the
player perform in the big moments or
what their stats was so there's a lot of
characteristics that go you know some
errors you know Jerry Rice played they
only paid two coverage so you know you
know what I mean so yeah it's a lot of
differential answers have you designated
who the greatest or how you list it's
really you know it's a unique group of a
bunch of individual guys they all delete
you know yeah
I see you pdv you gotta border memories
of insurance guys like
they're actually who the greatest is
like yo I mean like whoever got the job
done you know what I mean like
I mean I know it's a code at the
standards and what you compare players
for but it's whatever your beliefs but a
lot of people will put obviously rice
Moss T.O because those the guys that's
on the top of the charts of the stats
but you know if you're a player or
you're a fan of the game you might like
to the player for your reason you know
it may not be off the stats so it's a
buyer's level of ranking players and
leveling players because we're just
going off their stats but you don't have
like a guy that's like nah that guy's
like legit that's the guy I mean there's
a lot of guys in legit but it's like
you know what I mean it could be a lot
of different scenarios you know what I
mean you hear what Dion said about you I
love Deion Sanders whatever he said
though he said you know I'm gonna try to
summarize this bro he said uh this
weekend too what's up he got a big game
this weekend what was it uh Jackson yeah
first game on ESPN oh wow did you see
his 60 Minutes or no I need to watch it
because he's really creative yeah he is
he's legit nobody go ahead tell him that
uh someone's like oh what do you think
about Abby he's like yo ab's my guy you
know that's my guy and that's that's my
he says if he gets into the Hall of Fame
yeah that's gonna be nuts and they said
what do you mean oh he's like I haven't
been back since I've been he's like if a
b goes I'ma go and I don't ever go and
he goes you know he goes you know what
he might do she goes he goes he might
show up butt naked and I will
I will right
put me on the titties he said that nah I
think it's a really exciting moment in a
time that you know
you know make the Hall of Fame you know
we like to try to make it not a big deal
but you know we all play the game for a
reason per se like you went to the Army
you did it for a reason you know to be
the best to serve your country the best
and being a player you know you always
want to be the best and those type of
moments you know what I mean you you
know that's what it's all about you know
what I mean being the light and you
think you deserve to be in the Hall of
Fame
I mean as far as my work I put in of
course but you know to no one could feel
deserving you know I don't feel entitled
and deserve it I mean I don't live and
count on it like you know I got a long
hallways in my house you know I call
them the Hall of fans because at the end
of the day man as long as you
conducive and peaceful with yourself
about your work you know I can't be you
know
over analytic or overly emotional about
someone else who probably don't know
about football or just write about
football I kind of know but kind of
never was in that position of being a
receiver and being decisive ruthless and
aggressive you know imagine someone in
your face every place you gotta you know
what I mean so
you know different mentalities I take
even from Liberty City surviving
you know you know 58 Terriers there's a
block of John Doe so taking that
mentality of survival you know what I
mean the travel way to Central Michigan
never have been
and uh making it as the sixth round
you know and you can you get successful
and then you you know I kind of kind of
outsmarted the NFL a little bit so if
you like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
[Music]